e
du prix du panier d'épicerie?
Pour de nombreuses personnes, la
réponse passe par les cuisines
collectives.
Marie-Claude Morin.
- Les boîtes Alonzo sont
financées aux deux tiers par une
fondation. Le reste déboursé par
les participants.
- C'est vraiment économique.
Si tu as deux enfants à neuf
dollars pour les repas de la
semaine pour tes enfants.
- Pour ajuster la hausse des
prix des aliments afin de revoir
le budget hebdomadaire.
- On avait de la difficulté à
gérer le panier d'épicerie parce
que si on voulait faire la
recette, le panier était trop
cher.
- De 12 $ l'an dernier, le
budget total par portion est
passé à 15 $ en septembre.
- La hausse des aliments c'est
quelque chose à laquelle on est
conscient depuis plusieurs
années mais cette année sera
frappée plus fort.
- Les participants en cuisine
collective ont toujours
travaillé avec les rabais de la
semaine.
- On va avec les circulaires et
les spéciaux, les sortes de
viandes qui sont spéciales.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait comme
recettes...
- celles qui ne disposent pas de
budget supplémentaire doivent
être encore plus ingénieuses.
- Elles vont adapter les
recettes, réduire la portion de
viande, de la récupération de
fruits et légumes moches.
Faire appel à l'épicier probant
des prix en gros.
- Cuisiner en groupe permet
d'acheter en grande quantité et
d'économiser. Ça comporte aussi
d'autres avantages.
- Donner des idées de recettes.
À force d'en faire on a moins
d'idées.
- Travailler avec du monde et se
faire des amis. Quand on est
maman à la maison...
- 13 heures par semaine bien
investie entend et en arge